Sehen Sie? Sehen Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor ich zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden komme, muss ich Ihnen noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen.
Falls etwas unklar ist, unterbrechen Sie mich bitte.
Und so, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Lisa Wassermann.
Können Sie diese Namen langsam durch die Buchstaben?
Ja, Lisa schreibt sich L-I-S-A, Lisa.
Und Wassermann, W-A-S-S-E-R-M-A-N-N, Wassermann.
Am Ende zweimal N, Double N.
Wie kann ich Sie ansprechen? Frau Wassermann, ja?
Ja, ja.
Frau Wassermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. August 1965.
1965.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
66 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 Meter.
Haben Sie ungewollte Abobesuch genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie uns?
Seit drei Tagen habe ich ziemlich zunehmende Schmerzen im rechten Bein.
Besonders im Unterschenkel, im rechten.
Ich habe auch noch Schmerzen im Rücken unten im Bereich der Lendenwirbelsäule.
Habe ich auch Schmerzen, aber besonders im rechten Bein.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen?
Nein, langsam.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Eine bohrende Schmerzen oder?
Ja, sie sind so dumpf bohrend.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenskala?
Von eins bis zehn. Wobei sie unerträglich sind.
Ich würde sagen, sie sind mindestens fünf.
Wenn ich mich versuche etwas zu bewegen, etwas zu gehen, dann sind sie auch mehr.
Sieben bis acht.
In Ruhe fünf. Wenn Sie bewegen, sind sieben oder acht.
Strahlen die Schmerzen nicht auf?
Nein.
Wo genau ist die Schmerzen? Könnten Sie noch mal sagen?
Also im rechten Bein, aber besonders im Unterschenkel.
Rechten Bein, Unterschenkel.
Auch Füße? Haben Sie auch Fussschmerzen?
Im Fuß tut es auch weh, aber hauptsächlich im Unterschenkel.
Bis Knie, aber Schmerzenstrasse bis Knie.
Maximalen Knie.
Ist Ihnen ein geschwollenes Bein aufgefallen?
Nein. Geschwollen ist das nicht. Das sieht aber ein bisschen komisch aus.
Das sieht irgendwie, ist irgendwie ein bisschen weißlich.
Ah, weiß, okay.
Also im Vergleich zum anderen Bein.
Okay. In Ruhe, Sie haben keine Beschwerden, aber...
Nein, ich habe seit drei Tagen auch Schmerzen in Ruhe.
Vorher war das in Ruhe nicht. Vorher war das nur bei Bewegung.
Aber seit drei Tagen habe ich auch Ruhe Schmerzen.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse?
Ich kenne, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe keine Erklärung.
Keine Erklärung, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay. Ist Ihnen ein Gerötet aufgefallen?
Nein, das Bein ist blass geworden.
Rötung nicht, das ist eher ein bisschen blasser.
Beide sind blasser oder nur das rechte Bein ist blass.
Das rechte Bein.
Ist Ihnen ein Haar los aufgefallen? Haar los.
Veränderung?
Haarausfall.
Haarausfall habe ich nicht beobachtet, nein.
Im einen betroffenen Seite.
Das habe ich nicht beobachtet.
Ist die rechte Beine überwärmt?
Ist Ihnen eine Überwärmung aufgefallen?
Ich glaube eher, das ist kühler.
Das ist kälter.
Eher ist kühler, ja?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Waren Sie im letzten ein Monat im Wald?
Erinnern Sie sich an einen Insektenbiss?
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Ich war aber auch nicht lange in der Natur oder im Wald in letzter Zeit.
Leiden Sie Herzschlag oder Herzstopper?
Nein, Herzschwäche habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur hohen Blutdruck.
Blutdruck.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ich habe häufiger Husten, weil ich eine chronische Bronchitis habe.
Da muss ich ziemlich oft husten.
Sie haben nur Husten oder mit Auswurf?
Da kommt auch manchmal Schleim raus, besonders morgens, nach dem Aufstehen.
Nach der Nacht.
Wenn ich da husten muss, dann muss ich auch häufig Schleim abhusten.
Wie ist die Farbe des Auswurfes?
Ist der Farbe grün?
Nein, der ist meist weisslich, ein bisschen gelblich.
Manchmal im Winter, besonders im Herbst, muss ich auch mal ein Antibiotikum nehmen,
weil das dann schlimmer wird.
Dann habe ich auch manchmal Fieber dabei, aber das ist jetzt nicht der Fall.
Jetzt habe ich da kein Problem.
Rauchen Sie gerade auch?
Ja, rauchen tue ich ja.
Haben Sie einen Hautausschlag aufgeholt?
Nein, einen Hautausschlag nicht.
Haben Sie eine Verdauerprobleme?
Ich meinte, Diarrhe oder Verstopfung, aufgebläht?
Nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben keine Verdauerprobleme?
Nein, Verdauung ist gut. Verdauung ist bei mir gut.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Stoffreus?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, das Wasserlassen ist gut. Ich kann das Wasser auch gut halten.
Das geht, habe ich kein Problem.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Treppe steigen?
Wie viele Treppe könnten Sie ganz fernfrei laufen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich bin da faul. Wenn es eben geht, fahre ich mit dem Fahrstuhl.
Wir wohnen im ersten Stock und das sind nur zwei Treppen. Die kann ich ganz gut steigen.
Wenn Sie möchten, Sie laufen, nachdem wie viele Meter die Beschwerden gibt?
Seit drei Tagen habe ich diesen Schmerz in Ruhe, dauernd.
Vorher habe ich bemerkt, dass ich die letzten Wochen vielleicht 100 Meter gehen konnte.
Dann musste ich anhalten, weil mein Bein schmerzte.
Sie brauchten eine Pause?
Ja, ich musste stehen bleiben, ein, zwei Minuten. Dann ging es wieder besser.
Dann konnte ich wieder weitergehen.
Wie gesagt, das war in den letzten Wochen. Aber seit drei Tagen habe ich Dauerschmerz.
Wenn Sie rechte Beine hochlagern, verhindert das Ihre Schmerzen oder nicht?
Habe ich bisher nicht ausprobiert.
Auch tief lagern, Sie haben noch nicht bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, das Gefühl ist insgesamt nicht so gut wie im linken.
Sind bei Ihnen chronische Erkrankungen bekannt außer COPD?
Ich habe die chronische Bronchitis.
Dann habe ich die chronische Bronchitis.
Seit wann haben Sie Bronchitis?
Bronchitis ungefähr seit vier, fünf Jahren.
Seit wann haben Sie ATL-Hypertension?
Seit ich die chronische Bronchitis habe.
Und seit wann haben Sie die chronische Bronchitis?
Seit wann haben Sie ATL-Hypertension?
Bluthochdruck seit vier Jahren.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Erkrankung. Seit zwei Jahren muss ich auch ein Medikament gegen Osteoporose einnehmen.
Osteoporose. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Osteoporose?
Osteoporose, das ist schwierig. Das heißt Alendronsäure.
Einmal pro Woche.
Und dann nehme ich noch Vitamin D. Das nehme ich jeden Tag.
Können Sie die Alendronik-Säure-Dosierung?
Nein, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie stark die ist. Aber mein Mann bringt die Sachen gleich alle ins Krankenhaus.
Das habe ich eben vergessen. Alendronsäure weiß ich nicht. Bei Vitamin D steht 1000 hinter.
Vitamin D ist 1000. Würden Sie keine Operation?
Operationen habe ich gehabt. Doch. Als Kind, da war ich zehn Jahre alt, wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Als Kind, Blinde.
Dann hatte ich vor zwei Jahren einen Sturz beim Fahrradfahren. Da war mein linker Unterarm gebrochen.
Da waren beide Knochen am Unterarm gebrochen.
Linker Arm, ja?
Linker Unterarm.
Beide Knochen waren da gebrochen und da musste ich auch operiert werden.
Und dann hatte ich noch vor vier Jahren am linken Knie eine Spiegelung.
Da wurde der Meniskus eingerissen und da wurde er behandelt.
Bei der Spiegelung. Und das ist viel besser geworden.
Wann war die Knie-Spiegelung?
Vor vier Jahren.
Wie haben Sie behandelt mit diesem linken Unterarm? Eine Osteosynthese?
Ja, da ist ein Schraub und eine Platte reingekommen.
Nach einem oder zwei Monaten musst du diese Schrauben und Platten rausnehmen oder nicht?
Ja, das ist entfernt worden. Aber erst nach sieben oder acht Monaten ist das entfernt worden.
Sie haben schon ein Jahr gesagt, ihr rauche. Wie viele und seit wann?
Ja, ich rauche ungefähr pro Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten seit ungefähr 35 Jahren.
Seit?
Seit 35 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol süßig?
Ich trinke mal ein Glas Wein, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine routinische Frage.
Ich muss jede Patientin diese Frage stellen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Sind Ihnen Allergie und Verträglichkeit bekannt?
Habe ich nicht.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, wie ist Ihr Familiengesundheitszustand?
Was kann ich für Sie sagen? Wie ist Ihr Elterngesundheitszustand?
Mein Vater ist mit 76 Jahren verstorben an einem Lungenkrebs.
Sechs und?
Sechsundsiebzig. Er ist wegen Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Er hatte vorher Bronchitis und Gefäßverengung in beiden Beinen.
Der war im Ende dann schwer krank.
Die Mutter?
Die Mutter ist 84 Jahre alt. Sie lebt. Sie hat Alterszucker. Sie hat auch eine Osteoporose.
Geschwister habe ich keine.
Sie haben keine Geschwister? Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Entschuldigung. Sie haben gegen Bronchitis. Nehmen Sie Medikamente oder nicht?
Sie haben noch nicht erzählt.
Sie haben mich nicht gefragt.
Entschuldigung. Sie haben die Osteoporose gesagt? Okay.
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente ein. Das heißt einmal Viani. Da ist Cortison drin.
Viani nehme ich zweimal am Tag in der Regel.
Und ich nehme manchmal auch Sultanolspray. Aber nicht immer. Das mache ich bei Bedarf.
Können Sie Viani dosieren sagen?
Viani, was dahinter steht, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Die Zahl bringt mein Mann ja alles ins Krankenhaus.
Ich nehme das in der Regel zweimal pro Tag.
Zweimal pro Tag. Und anderes Inhalator?
Sultanol. Sultanolspray. Aber das mache ich nicht immer. Das mache ich so bei Bedarf.
Bei Bedarf, ja?
Dann nehme ich noch ein Mittel für den hohen Blutdruck oder gegen den hohen Blutdruck.
Was nehmen Sie?
Dann nehme ich Candesatan.
Candesatan.
Da weiß ich die Dosierung. Das ist 16. Candesatan 16.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe.
Einmal morgen eine halbe?
Nein, morgens eine ganze und abends eine halbe.
Abends halbe. Okay.
Sind Sie gerade Rentnerin? Rentnerin oder? Was machen Sie für die Kinder?
Nein, ich bin noch keine Rentnerin. Ich arbeite als Sekretärin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder. 30 Jahre alt und 28 Jahre alt. Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Wie ist Ihr gesundes Zustand?
Die sind gesund.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Ja, ich war in Kroatien.
In Kroatien war ich im April für zehn Tage. Aber ansonsten war ich in den letzten sechs Monaten nicht im Ausland.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich glaube ja. Meine Hausärztin achtet immer darauf.
Tragen Sie Sport nicht regelmäßig?
Nein, Sport habe ich früher gemacht. Früher habe ich Turnen gemacht und Yoga gemacht.
Aber in letzter Zeit mache ich keinen Sport mehr.
Vielen Dank für die Angaben.
Ich habe mir jede wichtige Frage gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzuzügen?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich wissen, was das für Schmerzen sind, was das für eine Ursache haben kann.
Weil sowas habe ich ja noch nicht gehabt. Und das ist sehr unangenehm, auch dieser Dauerschmerz.
An diesem Punkt kann ich nicht genau sagen. Aber aufgrund der Anmess-Angabe und der geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich Verdacht auf einen Gefäßverschluss.
Das heißt PVK im medizinischen Bereich.
Aber ich kann nicht genau sagen. Ich muss noch körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, okay.
Ultraschall und Labor. Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, werde ich Ihnen sofort informieren.
Okay, das können wir so machen. Gut, ja danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit sich vorzubereiten.
Und vielleicht gibt es von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen oder Ergänzungen.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich habe nicht gehört. Aber haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Nein, hat der Kollege schon ganz zu Anfang gefragt einmal.
Deswegen.
Gewicht ist gleich geblieben.
Okay. Und über die letzte Monatliche Brutung waren Sie schon in der Mönchpause?
Ja, das ist schon mindestens fünf Jahre her. Aber ich gehe regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin zur Kontrolle einmal im Jahr.
Das letzte Mal war ich im Februar da. Da war die Ärztin zufrieden.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie keine Trauma und Verletzungen an den Beinen gehabt?
Verletzungen? Nein, Verletzungen habe ich in letzter Zeit nicht gehabt an den Beinen.
Sagen Sie mir bitte, ob Sie Ihre Zähnegel, irgendwelche Anomalie oder Verform bemerkt?
Die Zähnegel sind etwas verformt. Da hatte ich auch schon mal einen Nagelpilz.
Das ist mal behandelt worden, aber so richtig weggegangen ist das nicht.
Die Nägel sind schon etwas verändert, aber am anderen Fuß auch.
Beides. Okay, kein Verstand. Danke schön.
Wenn jetzt keine Fragen sind, dann lasse ich Sie jetzt einige Minuten in Ruhe.
Dann machen wir gleich die Vorstellung. Dann bin ich der Oberarzt. Bis gleich.
Tschüss.
Wie sieht es aus?
Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit, ich würde gerne mit Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, habe ich.
Frau Wasserman ist 60 Jahre alt. Sie wiegt gerade 66 Kilogramm und 1,69 Meter groß.
Sie stellt sich mit rechten Beinem Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Seit wann sind die Schmerzen?
Seit drei Tagen habe sie in Ruhe Schmerzen.
Vor drei Tagen hatte sie auch Schmerzen, aber nur bei Bewegung.
Okay. Seit drei Tagen also ein Ruheschmerz?
Können Sie den Schmerz beschreiben?
Die Schmerzen sind dunst und bohrend.
Die Schmerzen liegen auf einer Skala von fünf Zehen.
Aktuell sind sieben oder acht Zehen.
Okay.
Der rechte Bein ist blass und kühl.
Lauten Patienten...
Okay, ich muss es finden.
Lauten Patienten strahlen die Schmerzen nirgendwo hinaus.
Aber sie klagt auch ein bisschen Rücken-Schmerzen und wirben Schmerzen.
Okay.
Die Frage nach Fieber, Herzrasen, Herz-Taschikade, das Rhythmus,
nach Schweiß, Schuttelfreus, Wasserlassen, Probleme, die da wurden verneint.
Sie klagt höchstens.
Aus diesem Grund seit Langem habe sie Bronchitis.
Sie haben einen Auswurf, vor allem am Morgen.
Die Auswurf sei klassisch Farbe und ein bisschen gelbig.
In Vorerkrankungen und Operationen, als sie Kind war, wurde die Apandemie durchgeführt.
Seit vier oder fünf Jahren hat sie Bronchitis.
Seit fünf oder fünf Jahren hat sie Arteriella Hypertensie.
Sie hat auch Osteoporose.
Okay.
Aufgrund eines Fahrradunfalls musste sie linken Radius und Ulna Osteosynthese durchgeführt.
Sie hatte auch ein Knieproblem.
Aufgrund der Meniskopatie wurde ein Arthroskop durchgeführt.
Sie hatte eine Probe gegen Osteoporose, Alendronikzöere.
Die Dosis war unbekannt.
Sie hatte eine Vitamin D-Ausbruchung jeden Tag.
Sie hatte 16 mg Kandesartan.
Morgen 1, abends halb.
Gegen Bronchitis nehmen sie Vianin, eine Steroide, zweimal täglich und einen Inhalator bei Bedarf.
Sie ist ein 35-jähriger Pakunkerraucher.
Sie raucht eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Sie kann sagen, es besteht ein Nikotin-Ab-Usus von 35 Packages.
Können Sie wiederholen diese ganzen Satze?
Es besteht ein Nikotin-Ab-Usus.
Das kann man schon sagen als Ab-Usus.
Wenn sie am Tag 3 Zigaretten raucht oder 2, dann würde ich nicht sagen, dass es ein Ab-Usus ist.
Aber eine Schachtel pro Tag und das so lange, über 35 Jahre kann man ruhig sagen,
es besteht ein Nikotin-Ab-Usus von 35 Packages.
Und Alkohol?
Alkohol ist gelegentlich selten, wenn sie Wein trinken.
Also nicht täglich.
Gut, ja.
Vater ist im Alter von 76 Jahren an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Ja, sagen Sie vielleicht, in der Familienanamnese ist erwähnenswert oder ist zu berichten.
Vater ist mit 76 Jahren an einem Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Mehr wissen wir nicht.
Aber versuchen Sie den medizinischen Begriff zu sagen.
Was hatte der Vater noch für Grunderkrankungen?
Sie hatte auch Bronchiitis.
Gefeß und Piavk.
Nicht sie, sondern er.
Er hatte auch eine wohl chronische Bronchiitis.
Wir sagen in diesem Fall wahrscheinlich eine COPD.
Und auch eine Gefäßerkrankung oder eine Piavk.
Ja, so weit ist das. Das sind die Angaben der Patientin.
Und die Mutter?
Mutter seitlich. Sie hatte Diabetes Typ 2 und Osteoporosis.
Wie alt ist die Mutter und lebt die Mutter noch?
Sie lebt die Mutter noch. Sie ist gerade 64 Jahre alt.
64 nicht. Dann wäre sie ja nur vier Jahre älter als die Patientin.
Ja genau.
84.
Das wäre eine ganz junge Mutter.
Ja, entschuldigung.
Das macht nichts, aber es ist mir nur aufgefallen.
Genau, ist unmöglich.
Also die Mutter ist 84 Jahre alt. Sie lebt noch.
Und sie hat ein Diabetes Meditus Typ 2 und ebenfalls eine Osteoporose.
Osteoporose.
Sie ist die Sekretärin in Reksanwald. Sie hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie hat eine Reise gemacht.
Jetzt wollte ich noch einmal was fragen zu den Schmerzen.
Ich habe verstanden, die Patientin hat seit drei Tagen einen starken Ruheschmerz im rechten Bein, besonders im Unterschenkel.
Das ist der Ruheschmerz.
Und Sie haben gesagt, vorher hatte sie einen Schmerz bei Belastung?
Oder habe ich das richtig verstanden? Davor?
Davor hatte sie Schmerzen nur bei Bewegung.
Bei Bewegung? Was war das für eine Bewegung? Oder wie stark war die Bewegung?
Sie hat gesagt, nach 100 Metern hatte sie Schmerzen.
Sie können das sagen.
Vorher berichtet die Patientin, dass sie nach ungefähr 100 Metern Gehstrecke schmerzbedingt anhalten musste, stoppen musste.
Sie konnte nicht weitergehen, weil es so schmerzte.
Und dann nach einer bestimmten Zeit ging es wieder besser.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, mein Aufgrund der anämestischen Angabe zu geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf eine PAVK.
Studium ist gerade eins, weil sie, Entschuldigung, nie eins, drei, Entschuldigung, drei.
Sie hat inzwischen einen Ruheschmerz mit gewissen Veränderungen, kühle Haut, blasse Haut.
Sie hatte vorher wohl schon eine PAVK, eine belastungsbedingte PAVK im Sinne einer Claudicatio Intermittens wahrscheinlich.
Claudicatio Intermittens mit Studium ist drei.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Wir machen jetzt ja keine Fachprüfung.
Wichtig ist nur, dass Sie versuchen, bei einem medizinischen Begriff zu sagen.
Was wäre denn differenzial diagnostisch, woran noch zu denken?
Differenzial diagnostisch TVT. Ich würde sagen TVT Aufgrund des Reises an einem Mäse.
Aber dafür spritzt es belastende Beine und Kühlbeine dagegen.
Ja, sie hat auch keine Schwellung bemerkt. Zumindest ist das Bein nicht geschwollen.
Ja, käme dann eventuell auch eine Lumboischalgie in Betracht, ein Wurzelreizsymbrom.
Wie bitte?
Eine Lumboischalgie, ein Bandbleibenvorfall.
Bandbleibenvorfall, genau.
Durchaus Patienten Hauptschmerz in den Extremitäten und gar nicht so sehr im Rücken.
Sie hat ja gesagt, ja, in der LWS hat sie auch häufig mal Rückenschmerzen.
Sie hat eine Osteoporose. Also man muss zumindest mal dran denken an eine Differenzial diagnostisch.
Ich würde auch den Verdacht auf eine PVK äußern als erstes.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch sicherlich auch einen Bandbleibenvorfall, einen Diskus-Kollaps abklären.
Das muss man klären. Vielleicht könnten Sie in der Befragung auch noch die Patienten fragen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn sie husten, niesen oder lachen, verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Husten, Schmerz kann das oft verstärken, gerade wenn sie so eine chronische Bronchitis hat.
Die Patientin hat ja wahrscheinlich doch eine COPD aufgrund ihres Nikotinabusus des Langen.
Und da muss man zumindest, differenzial diagnostisch, würde ich eben die Frage eher nach einem Diskus-Kollaps stellen.
Eine TVT glaube ich jetzt nicht so sehr von der Klinik. Aber in Richtung Diskus-Kollaps muss man zumindest mal schauen.
Das werden Sie auch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung natürlich eher schneller feststellen.
Durch bestimmte Testungen der Muskel, der Nerven, denungsschmerz und Lasäge und umgekehrter Lasäge und die Reflexe.
Aber das wird einem dann ja auch ein bisschen auffallen.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Kann es auch die Wirbelsäule Spontan Kompressionsflattöre sein?
Ja, natürlich gibt es auch Kompressionsflattöre. Aber die machen dann in der Regel eher den Hauptschmerz in der Wirbelsäule, glaube ich.
Wo die Kompressionsfraktur ist, da würde ich sagen, ist wahrscheinlich das Punktum Maximum des Schmerzes.
Und nicht so sehr im Unterschenkel. Das ist eher, ja, man muss dran denken.
Aus dem Prinzip.
Ja, gut. Ja, danke erst mal. Ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Sie sollten sich konsequent bemühen bei der Vorstellung vom Oberarzt versuchen, Sie medizinische Ausdrücke zu machen.
Sie sagt ja, sie klagt über Husten.
Wir können sie eventuell sagen über Tussis oder produktiven Husten, produktive Tussis.
Also mit besonders morgendlichem Auswurf weißlich-fleimig oder etwas gelblich.
Das ist dann hauptsächlich morgens. Und die Patientin berichtet ja auch über gewisse Exazzebationen im Winter,
dass sie dann eventuell sogar Antibiotika-pflichtig ist. Das spricht alles eher dann auch für eine COPD.
So von der Schilderung der Patientin her. Wir haben ja noch keine Unterlagen von anderen Untersuchungen, von anderen Ärzten.
Das bezieht sich bisher nur auf die anamnestischen Schilderungen der Patienten.
Ja, danke. Haben Sie einen Prüfungstermin?
Noch nicht. Mein Prüfungstermin steht in den Sternen.
In den Sternen steht der? Das ist in Deutschland nicht gut, wenn etwas in den Sternen steht.
Aber Sie haben sich angemeldet.
Ja, ich habe letztes Jahr im Dezember angemeldet.
Oha.
Ja, ich warte auf, wahrscheinlich, voraussichtlich werde ich im Oktober oder...
Ah so, ja gut. Aber dann haben Sie noch etwas zu sagen.
In was für einem Fachbereich haben Sie bisher gearbeitet?
Gynäkologe.
Gynäkologe. Das war das Thema heute nicht so sehr, die Gynäkologie.
Aber das haben Sie aber als Gynäkologe auch gut gelöst, dieses Thema.
Sie waren eine Patientenwartfrau.
Ja, ja, alles klar. Gut, ich bedanke mich und wünsche allen erstmal einen schönen Abend
und gerne nächste Woche um 18 Uhr wieder.
Vielen Dank.
Alles klar, ich sage tschüss. Ciao.